我是苏北独生子女，
我老公是河南农村，
有个哥哥，
我俩都是35岁结婚，
7年上海定居，
我月入大概1万，
我老公2万，
然后每月房贷我俩公积金是分别扣1500，
我老公是在还4000，
两个女儿五岁和两岁，
呃，
外婆帮带，
然后现在是我老公对我妈妈就是动了两次手，
第一次动手大概是姐姐一岁的时候，
当时是爷爷奶奶带娃，
我妈过来照顾我做月子，
后来就留下来工作了，
爷爷奶奶以他们老家的方式带娃，
我妈会插手，
他们心里不舒服，
我就是认为自己老大不小了，
还要受我妈妈的管教，
我老公让我当睡客，
让我妈妈先回老家，
我妈就是认为在讲他走，
当时就发生了冲突，
我老公就动手了，
后来我妈妈就搬出去了，
后来的话就是因为发生一些婆媳矛盾，
爷爷奶奶就是就总是找借口回家嘛，
后来我就沉不住，
吵架了，
爷爷奶奶就到老大家带孙子了，
后面去请也不愿意，
也就不过来了，
然后我只能冲我妈带孩子，
然后第二次动手是两个娃抢玩具，
妹妹哭了，
外婆埋怨了几句，
我老公下班一直回来玩手机，
我先哄妹妹，
妹妹看见就吃醋嘛，
呃，
就推开妹妹要我抱，
爸爸就管叫姐姐打了嘴巴，
妹妹害怕这手要外婆抱，
外婆就生气，
故意把妹妹的手打开，
说我才不抱你呢。
然后爸爸就起来又起来就打我妈了，
就是还说我的小孩只能我打，
不能离岗，
那除了以上这几点啊，
我还总觉得其他的一些矛盾，
就是男方家庭条件不太好，
父母没有退休金，
我老公有点自卑，
认为我家看不起他家，
第2点是爷爷奶奶不出钱不出力，
不帮衬我们，
还要补贴他们生活费，
我妈是出钱又出力，
心里。
不太平衡。
第3点是我生二胎，
我妈是反对的，
然后生完爷爷奶奶也没有过来看，
电话也没有。
第4点就是我妈带娃大多数是哄着娃的，
我老公带娃基本上都是，
呃，
管教的时候娃能哭两个小时。
然后第5点就是我个人而言，
我有点小性子，
情商低，
不懂人情世故，
我老公话少，
不喜欢浪漫，
有点冷暴力，
就这几年的夫妻关系来看啊，
虽然他是每个月上涨工资，
但是我感觉他没有那么爱我，
也没有也不关心我。
然后现在的问题我就是在想要不要分开，
不知道这个决定对不对。
还有我想争取两个小孩的抚养权，
大概是胜算多少，
但什么准备她动手，
动手打丈母娘严重吗？
呃，
不是很严重，
一次也不是很严重，
第二次的话就是有点那个擦伤，
膝盖破了，
然后我妈妈脖子里边有点擦伤，
而是这个行为是不对的，
她动手打丈母娘了之后，
就你这头还有亲然亲属，
还有其他亲属在嘛，
就没有个后患了嘛，
打了就打了嘛，
没有让他有一个什么就报警啊，
但是第一次没有抱嘛，
第二次报妈就叔说了，
然后那个警察上门调解嘛，
先开始我老公也道歉了，
但是我妈妈觉得态度不好嘛，
不满意啊，
然后我老公就就不同意调解了，
然后我们就去派出所做了那个笔录，
后来我老公就。
做完笔录以后，
他就就相当于就走了嘛，
过了好几天才回来，
回来也不说话，
我说这个事情怎么解决，
然后他说呃，
让警察来找他，
他的态度也很消极啊，
他也没有想解决这个事情，
你家里除了妈妈还有哪些亲戚在呀？
爸爸是不在了吗？
没有啊，
爸爸在，
爸爸在老家，
因为我还有爷爷呢，
他在带爷爷哦，
爸爸在老家，
家里你有兄弟是吧，
你是独女啊，
我是独女，
对，
也没有什么，
舅舅呀，
叔叔呀，
就是男丁什么，
我就在想这个可以啊，
舅舅他怎么敢跟丈母娘动手，
他没有考虑过跟丈母娘手之后会带来的后果，
然后就是我老公，
他就就觉得我妈可能带孩子没有一些边界感，
有点插，
是我们小家庭嘛，
然后就各种看不顺眼，
然后觉得我们家有点，
因为我们家是城里的，
他可能有点自卑，
觉得我们看不起他们家，
他的自尊心还是很强的，
就是说这时子跟跟他动手，
给跟丈母娘动手，
这事儿等于是不了了之，
他没有为此付出任何的代价，
也没有第一没有拘留，
第二导致赔款，
第三你们也没有对他实施任何的这样一个惩罚，
是这意思吗？
是的，
因为我个人性格就比较懦弱，
没有没有太大的主见，
然后就是我现在就是下定决心。
我是想分开的，
然后就是有两个小孩嘛，
然后我再说一下那个情况，
就是我父母这边可以可以是完全帮助我的，
然后我父母都有退休金嘛，
然后家里我父母也有存款还是挺多，
大概有60个W，
然后我老家房子大概是60个W，
在学区嘛，
他的父母是没有退休金，
没有存款，
然后父亲还有患有心脏方面的疾病，
然后没有办法帮我们带小孩，
然后我就想能不能争取两个小孩的抚养权权，
我该不该争取？
嗯，
从该不该这个角度来说的话，
我认为肯一是该争取的原因是什么？
因为他不光对丈母娘动手，
他对孩子也动手啊，
嗯，
他就是有会倾向啊，
那你该不该始么？
你该成对他是没有对我动过手的，
对我会冷冷暴力，
就是每次发生矛盾的时候就不说话，
拒绝沟通。
你这话说的我都宁可，
他有本事敢打我，
他打我妈试试，
打我孩子试试，
我个人的收入大概是我老公的一半，
其实我们在上海收入不算太高，
我怕真是两个孩子又争取不到，
他在上海是干什么工作的呀？
嗯，
他是it行业的，
然后我是银行编制的，
我的工作，
我的工资虽然不算太高，
但是我的工作比较稳定，
假设他能力把孩子都给你，
你将来的生活打算怎么安排呢？
因为你们买的那个房子是在婚后买的吗？
在婚后买的，
在上海嘛。
呃，
我是有这么考虑的，
就是等到小孩，
如果说上小学，
因为我们上海郊区的这个，
这个学校也不是很好，
如果说能到小学的话，
我就回老家找份工作，
然后住在我爸爸妈妈家里面，
然后他们帮我带孩子，
然后我老家的那个房子是有学区的，
那你要是回去了之后，
你的工作嗯，
能搞得定吗？
嗯，
这个心态不确定，
那我觉得这个事还得从长计议啊，
主要是我们要权衡这件事情对自己的工作的影响，
以后生存的影响，
对孩子的影响，
所以这事儿还得从长计议，
我感觉你老公，
嗯，
实话说啊，
他既不爱你，
他可能是因为不爱你，
所以他不害怕跟你撕破脸，
不害怕得罪你，
他也有点欺负人。
人，
他欺负人可能就是因为你们家就你一个独生女，
那样就算把你妈打了，
好像也没有人能找他什么麻烦，
没有人能报复他或者干嘛的她所以才敢那么放肆打两回，
你现在等于是你妈妈已经回去了，
是不是我妈妈现在就多一个房子在外面，
还是帮我带孩子，
因为我是有点想分开的，
想分开的话，
可能会因为我妈妈就是那个调解，
调解到一半嘛，
那边还没有那个大结，
那个案件，
嗯，
我是想给他沉重打击拘留的哈。
但是警察那边还没有最终半解，
如果想要以后他不再欺负你们，
但你不欺负你妈妈，
这事就得我，
我觉得就得你，
就得该追就你管他居，
不然的话，
他以后更肆无肆无忌惮了，
他更觉得欺负你们，
你们能把我怎么着呢，
更那个啥了，
就不调节，
就该拘就拘，
因为我想这两个小孩子的抚养权哈，
我现在要不要直接搬出来，
就跟他分开来，
如果你想争取两个孩子抚养权的话，
你就把两个孩子都在带在身边，
然后你妈妈帮你带着，
先跟他分开住一段时间，
比如说再过个三年，
其中的大的那个闺女已经8岁了，
现在那个闺女是5岁了，
如果说他一直这三年都在你身边的话，
那你争取孩子抚养权的概率要大一些，
尤其是假设你跟他分居，
这段期间他又找别人了，
你看跟别人生孩子了，
他可能对两个孩子也没有那么执着了，
没准就能能达成一个共识，
如果现在提分开，
争取的可能性不是很大是吗？
不是很大，
因为人家第一有稳定的工作，
第二虽然说他爸妈帮不上忙，
但他是请得起保姆的，
是不是？
是啊，
那在这种情况下，
你知道两个孩子都归你。
话，
呃，
概率是比较小的，
除非你自己爸爸孩子都已经生活两三年了，
孩子一起生活也被照顾的很好，
你把这些证据都留下来，
并且这两个孩子相互之间感情也很好，
也不愿意彼此分开，
再加上他那头可能都要再婚了，
对不对，
他婚都家生孩子了等等这一系列的加起来，
才有可能这两个孩子也这两，
而且有可能都归你，
嗯，
好吧，
好的，
嗯，
好好，
谢谢龙飞姐，
嗯，
我大概心里有个方向，
好，
拜拜，
再见，
嗯。